relations Alzheimer's is one of the
fastest growing and most debilitating
diseases of our time it not only causes
serious memory loss but often leads to
loss of Independence and eventually
death Joe montman many was diagnosed
with Alzheimer's at age 54. his doctor
gave him a grim prospect that I may not
recognize my family in five to seven
years and she's like she told me I had a
10-year life expectancy you know we were
shocked
I've been fortunate in my progression
hasn't been as bad as they expected but
we have seen declines and it's hot it's
it's just it's a challenging disease
scientists together with pharmaceutical
companies say they develop drugs that
can slow down the Disease by up to seven
months and possibly longer by removing
so-called protein plaques from patients
brains still no cure but it's considered
a breakthrough after Decades of failing
to find medicines that work the oxidized
I think these drugs give us hope that we
can do things these are the these are
the first drugs of a new generation okay
they're not the they're not the end of
the story the beginning of a news story
sure their safety concerns the safety
concerns with any drugs the the thing is
we know what those safety concerning
concerns are like you mentioned this
swelling or this bleeding into the brain
which sounds very dramatic but it's
something we can monitor scientists here
at the world's largest gathering of
Alzheimer's researchers call it a start
of a new era with Alzheimer no longer
being an untreatable disease but others
are more skeptical those scientists
accuse the pharmaceutical industry of
giving patients false hope
Dutch Professor Marshall all the record
says the new drugs don't have enough
benefits for patients he urges
scientists and the industry to focus
more on other causes of Alzheimer's than
only protein plaques it's clear that
these have been more or less neglected
as the pharmaceutical companies are now
focusing on something which is close to
the market and they want more and more
and all the companies when they say that
see that it's more or less
take giving profits and they also want
the share of the profits it's estimated
that the Nano map will cost around
twenty six thousand dollars per patient
per year the company hopes to receive
approval to sell it in the United States
somewhere next year it could take longer
before it will be available in the rest
of the world stop fast and Al Jazeera
Amsterdam